what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be reacting to body
two
by tion wayne and russ millions before i
start do not forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring the
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of daily videos
as you guys already know my instagram is
in the description if you guys want to
submit
an instagram or a video clip to me or a
song to react to
send it to me on instagram that is the
best way to reach me and follow me while
you
are there okay
[Music]
english skill name for yono big bad girl
name abiotics
are they british this english girl named
fiona
africa
[Music]
okay high as a kite never sober they
like to do drugs i got it weed
free
[Music]
[Music]
sorry your sis got bent over oh my gosh
of our body if i beat it i wearing a
johnny adiola when i roll with the keys
i know this song actually i don't give a
[ __ ] i'm a rapper
living in it you smoke up in my hotel
building it
okay so he's just talking about all the
cool things that he does
one of those he mentioned was getting
um i don't know if i could say this on
youtube but like sexual
favors right from a woman while
he smokes he talks about him being lit
having a lot of fun
um just doing a lot of fun stuff and now
we got a nice car
right here and these people they're
hanging out of the car which i don't
think is very safe but like i'm not
going to tell you how to live your life
you know what i mean
still chatting to my bro [ __ ] that man i
don't give a [ __ ]
why you wanna get small cigarette
english english your name fiona
african doradiola buddhism
[Music]
e1 i'm bringing it back dropper garlic
on no one's been slapped i'm in the
backseat with a brown in yeah with the
biggest the backs on the shoulder
they give us the biggest chat but live
in the flesh didn't see no hands
anything green get bunny's a capcom no
one in three times freeze
okay so he's talking about all the
different girls that he
can get like he couldn't decide there
was like i think becky was one girl's
name
i forgot the other girl's name but there
was girl one girl two and he's like
which one
should i take home and he could not
decide at all
you don't want to get left in a mess
going shot from the right and the left
50 g's will pay for your life get blazed
like cali with no cigarette
english girl named fiona straight
hennessy with no cola
[Music]
it's ironic cause he got waited for
spilling his drink on me
he got wedded oh that's kind of clever
he got wedded for spilling his drink on
me
i don't know if like wedded is supposed
to be used in a different
term but that's that that was clever
that was clever i said
just to help him breathe my drum when
it's an internal bleed but i don't care
for your nickname or your last name
anyone can get all right when i'm still
up on the rose gonna live
still chatting to my bros [ __ ] that man
i don't give a [ __ ]
why you wanna get small cigarette
english english girl named fiona
african daughter
[Music]
they're just talking about the party
life long story short
girls drugs and like they're doing some
really cool dancing like
this looks like a party i would want to
be invited to never stepping out of my
lane man i did a lot of [ __ ] man part of
my name
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
s o s for an e green a f g s and e t m i
don't know about them got rams on me
i see one of them i see freeze i make
the hunting
easy sucking the streets shout out my
three times freeze
don't touch my watch me must be crazy
how to roll lead then i switched to the
ap but it's like an earthquake sign like
hey
she knows me she's calling me baby 23
hours how to bring that back
a roll next can't face me time be money
so [ __ ] can't pay me swing both way so
bring your leg
okay so he's talking about how rolex's
don't face him so you're saying i have
money
i don't care how much money you have
because i have money and that stuff does
not impress me
with everybody when i come and get jiggy
when i ain't talking but you know what
i'm strapped
when you talk about stacks
okay just reiterating his point i pay a
hundred thousand in taxes so i make
a ton of money it's like what twenty
percent of his income so
a lot of money garlene get shot for the
back seat two man pulled up on banana
batsy
that's that top boy like ashley taffy
swing getting up badly
good day scream puppy she holds my
weapon she makes me happy you know what
i'm tapping
[Music]
[Music]
so they end the song just talking about
cigarettes
and a girl african
girl and what do they say british girl
then fiona that's clever
i'm gonna give this song four or five
i'm gonna give it a five this i actually
knew the course already so that was
exciting but it was actually
so catchy and yeah i really liked it so
five out of five i would recommend
listen to it again
uh before i end the video guys do not
forget to subscribe to the channel
as you guys know i'm trying to hit 20
000 subscribers that's a really big goal
for the channel and ring the
notification bell i'll talk to you guys
next time